and low cannot find my shoes my Marella
Mary Jane tabies his profile is gone I'm
like oh this stole my shoes he is
actually deleting my number so I go and
I make a Tik Tok and I expose that b for
the thief that he is find out he cheated
on his girlfriend he gave the girlfriend
my shoes he calls me he says I didn't
steal them I didn't take them I don't
know what you're doing people are
calling me and harassing me and telling
me that I've done something I haven't
done can you please like go back to your
apartment and like look like he's
literally telling me to go look later I
get the screenshot of his girlfriend
wearing my shoes I send that to
him what the hell okay this is a crazy
story in what time and I'll bring you
your Sho I go pick up my shoes he is so
smug he is literally like smiling and
like giggling and I just go up to him I
say what the fck is wrong with you why
would you do this and he's like I don't
know I thought I could get away with it
did you ever talk to him again actually
he contacted me after I picked up the
shoes me to take down the video he was
like I feel like he got what what up
guys well welcome to the chest hly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel bring
that notification Bell that way you're
going to be notified of my daily videos
like the video on your way in and get
yourself a women shouldn't vote t-shirt
the link to these are in the description
guys they are so soft and literally the
best material and they'll you'll get
women coming up to you left right and
Center to say how awesome you are um
okay so this video says men at Home
Depot show women what dating over 50 is
really like uh logical reactions 101
finally my first time getting hit on in
Home Depot and he's not even attractive
I don't know what I'm doing wrong but
I'm here all the time so for all you
people who are like go to Home Depot
that's where all the men are no they're
not well I would probably say that one
of your issues is that you're on Tik Tok
doing exactly what men don't want to be
involved in trashing them he wasn't even
fine but you went to Home Depot to be
approached and a man approached you
that's number number one number two
you're not the center of the universe
everybody is doing their thing these men
might be married they might have kids to
get back home too or they may not care
about what you're doing they might just
glance at you and say oh she's cute and
continue walking on I'm not interested
I'll say this because I know men won't
get offended and they'll understand what
I mean you can't condition a dog to do a
certain trick and then get frustrated
when they do that certain trick to a tea
what are you calling me a dog the men
get the analogy modern women women have
taken it upon themselves to be
absolutely obnoxious out here in these
dating streets and then wonder why a man
is not interested doesn't approach and
in fact will avoid you at all cost thank
yourself next time you look at this
video modern women logic what's the
worst date you've ever been on I was
walking around in SoHo and I cross path
with this guy who's very cute I find out
that we had match on Tinder because he
messages me so we go out for drinks we
eventually hang out again so he comes
over everything's great we hook up and
then the next morning we're chatting
like I go brush my teeth he even offers
to show me a Spotify playlist so he's
like oh can't find it I'm like all right
whatever I have work I say goodbye I'm
just chilling in my bed and then I look
over to my shoe rack and I see there's a
space where shoes belong I look high and
low cannot find my shoes my Marella Mary
Jane tabies I go to the app nowhere to
be found his profile is gone I'm like oh
this stole my shoes so I go then to my
call log cuz I know he called me when he
I buzzed him up call deleted so when he
is looking for a Spotify playlist he is
actually deleting my number so I go and
I make a Tik Tok and I expose that bit
for the thief that he is find out he
cheated on his girlfriend he gave the
girlfriend my shoes he calls me and says
I didn't steal them I didn't take them I
don't know what you're doing people are
calling me and harassing me and telling
me that I've done something I haven't
done can you please like go back to your
apartment and like look like he's
literally telling me to go look later I
get the screenshot of his girlfriend
wearing my shoes I send that to him no
message just that and he's like I you
got me he's like just what the hell okay
this is a crazy story and what time and
I'll bring you your Sho I go pick up my
shoes he is so smug he is literally like
smiling and like giggling and I just go
up to him I say what the [__] is wrong
with you why would you do this and he's
like I don't know I thought I could get
away with it did you ever talk to him
again actually he contacted me after I
picked up the shoes me to take down the
video he was like I feel
like he got what innocent person is
getting hurt his ex-girlfriend you know
the irony in this and I want to say that
I am glad that she actually did make a
Tik Tok to expose this guy because we
all know that you don't take things that
don't belong to you but it's the thing
that I've heard multiple times by modern
women and that is these men out here are
moving sloppy you invite a woman back to
your house and you don't even know her
you know what I'm going to start
stealing from these men and they'll get
the picture not to let anyone in their
home but when they do it then it's a
travesty and everybody should be yeah
that's really true like how many women
have gotten so much money out of guys no
one cares but the Tinder swindler was
huge was literally huge because he could
get resources from women and I think
you're going to keep seeing this
phenomenon in society I think women are
going to keep being overpaid for their
work so I think that some men are just
going to look at the market and say if I
become really good-look if I go to the
gym a million hours a day I can just get
a rich lady to pay for everything I I
think you're gonna see this more and
more not to Justice the thing that I
wish the most is that that female
intuition would have kicked in in this
situation and then she could have
avoided all of this interesting so I
have a legitimate question for all the
women out there dating and dating in
your 40s is like don't really want to do
it but um would you dismiss a potential
partner um because he doesn't check a
lot of the boxes that you have um like I
mean he's got a great job he is
respectful he is kind he's a gentleman
but like he doesn't have kids and that
is like a big deal I've dated men that
don't have kids and they don't
understand um so I I'd like to know like
I mean how picky can you be at 40 am I
crazy like how how picky you give up
this person or would you would you give
him a chance let me know in the
comments can I ask you a quick question
you don't know these women why instead
of having a conversation with him and
making sure he knows hey I have children
are you cool with that and exploring the
dynamic how come it make sense to ask a
total stranger what would they do in the
situation I could see if you asked your
neighbor or somebody in the community
but you don't know these people they
could be all the way across the world
totally different situation totally
different personality totally different
set of circumstances you be taking their
advice and end up single and lonely
because if it's one thing that modern
women like that single strong
independent women like is keeping other
women single and lonely be careful out
here in these streets yo I keep saying I
want a husband and I really do want a
husband but the main reason why I want a
companion is cuz these bills these bills
are annoying and I want some help okay I
want to go 5050 60 40 7030 I don't want
to do 100% of any of any of these bills
by myself no more like that's the real
reason and I think that that's a really
good reason cuz I'm sure it's out there
that want to go 60 yeah I do think as
the economy gets worse I do think you're
going to see more couples get together
like you saw a lot of people get
together during Co um but you you know I
I don't know if that's the number one
reason you should get with someone but
honestly after a certain age I don't
really think it's about feelings anymore
like after a certain age I I literally
think a lot of people it's just going to
be an economic decision because like
what's the alternative living alone with
a bunch of chicks or figuring out how to
get along with a guy 5050 7032 with me
you feel me I'm tired I'm just tired of
doing by myself like I'm sick and TI
tired like I wish somebody would just
say you know what Jackie today don't
worry about it I got this today I got
this today and I got this today I'm
tired of doing everything by myself I'm
sick and tired I'm sick and tired God I
see what you've done to other people
please please please please please
please please I'm patiently waiting but
a girl can only wait for so long but
this is the thing the church leaves
chicks single too because it pushes a
lot of feminist stuff and it tells you
that you should just sit and wait for
God to send you a husband instead of
going to become the thing that men
desire they also yeah so that's why you
see a lot of like older single women in
churches the interesting thing about
this is that you have a lot of men that
actually see these strong independent
women struggling and they say to
themselves wow it really looks like she
needs help but unfortunately in today's
society because you don't want me to
approach you in the parking lot the gas
gas station Church the bar work the gym
your home the grocery store the post
office almost quite literally anywhere
then you don't get approached it's
gotten to the point in some situations
where if a woman is knocked out a man
doesn't even go in there and help she
could be unconscious and the man still
would be like hey can somebody call the
police as silly stupid and ludicrous
well we just watched a video where a
woman literally is suing a guy over CPR
CPR you can't make this up you can't
sounds you might think as a man she's
knocked out surely she'll want somebody
to help she's unconscious it's better to
get help than to have a serious injury
but modern women strong independent
women have been taught by Society
regardless of what situation or state
you're in you don't need a man's help
you don't need anyone's help but
specifically that of a guy and so if man
comes over and tries to help then he
runs the risk of I didn't need you to
protect me get your hands off me what
are you trying to do to me are you
trying to take advantage of me I'm
taking you to the hospital lady you see
the ambulance right here oh he tried to
do something to me he tried to take
advantage of me it's then that men have
that movie play in their mind almost
quite literally a 100 times in 5 minutes
and they step back and say you know what
maybe I'll let some of these other women
around here handle it maybe I'll see if
another guy can handle it maybe I'll
step back and call 911 it shouldn't be
this way but unfortunately like I said
with the conditioning that Society has
put in some of these women and not only
preached it but the women have taken
hold of it and adopted it then you get
what you get and that's unfortunate but
that's just my opinion until the next
video I'm out yeah guys you're going to
see a lot of societal changes in the
next 10 years and there's someone on the
show last night who even said what is it
going to be like after AI girlfriends
come in AI robot girlfriends like
imagine these chicks can cook they they
do everything for the guy they like
deliver him a meal whatever oh no that's
G to be an interesting world but let me
know what you guys think in the comments
like the video on your way out subscribe
to the channel and get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt today I'll talk
to you next time